[Musik]
hallo meine Lieben heute gibt es
italienische Milchbrötchen wir machen
muddy Tozzi mit pistazienfüllung ihr
könnt sie aber auch füllen wie Ihr
möchtet ich zeige euch heute das
Grundrezept und eins kann ich euch
verraten die bekommen glatte 10 von 10
Punkte von mir also los geht's mit dem
Teig zuallererst machen wir einen
Vorteig ein sogenannten tankzong und
dafür nehmt euch einfach ein bisschen
Mehl und Milch und gibt das in eine
Pfanne das ganze dann ein bisschen
eindicken lassen und sofort in die
Schüssel geben das habe ich hier schon
vorbereitet und auskühlen lassen ich
schreibe euch aber alle ganz genauen
Mengenangaben natürlich wie immer hier
unten in die Infobox sie müsste ich
natürlich jetzt nichts merken und ich
hatte sogar alle Zutaten für dieses
Rezept zu Hause musst du noch nicht mal
einkaufen gehen vielleicht habt ihr das
ja auch und könnt direkt loslegen so ich
benutze heute die Küchenmaschine und
werde jetzt erstmal meinen Vorteig so
ein bisschen auflockern gebe da Zimmer
warme Butter dazu und Eier und dann
eigentlich auch schon eine restlichen
Zutaten aber mein Tipp das ja auch
machen könnt ist Trockenhefe schon mal
hier mit zum Mehl zu geben und Zucker
auch schon mit reingeben
auch noch mal den süßen Geschmack ist
werden ja süße softbanks und einmal vor
verrühren so und dann wird alles zu
einem Teig verknetet
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt schon ein Teil vom
Mehl dazu gegeben und stand jetzt ist es
so ein typischer Kuchenteig aber ich
wechsele jetzt gerade mal meinen Aufsatz
das ist gerade der schneebesenaufsatz
und den brauche ich gleich einfach nicht
mehr
so das hol ich mir gleich noch und da
gebe ich jetzt einmal den Knethaken dazu
denn es wird dir jetzt ähm so ein
relativ ich will jetzt nicht sagen
fester Hefeteig aber er wird auf jeden
Fall so fest dass wir den Knethaken
jetzt dafür brauchen so jetzt noch das
restliche Mehl dazu und dann schön lange
kneten lassen also ich bin da hier bei
mir wirklich einfach bei mir bei der
knetstufe und lass das dann so fünf bis
acht Minuten kneten und anschließend
auch noch mal mit den Händen
[Musik]
die Maschine hat jetzt sechs Minuten
lang geknetet der Teig fühlt sich
richtig gut an aber ich habe ja gesagt
ich wollte auf der Arbeitsfläche doch
noch einmal mich vergewissern dass da
jetzt wirklich genug Mehl drin ist es
ist so ein richtig
feuchter Teig der klebt nur noch so ganz
leicht und ich gebe jetzt nur noch
minimal Mehl hier auf meine Silikonmatte
und dann wollte ich das einfach nur noch
zu einer Kugelform ich brauche das immer
einmal noch mit den Händen fühlen und
dann gebe ich das zurück in die Schüssel
und lasse 60 Minuten gehen
[Musik]
so die Ruhezeit ist um und tada ein
riesengroßer Hefeteig der richtig schön
fluffig aufgegangen ist genauso brauchen
wir Leute ich muss einmal rein duschen
ich liebe das richtig fettes fein so das
gebe ich jetzt hier einmal auf die
Silikon Backmatte der Teig fühlt sich so
weich an ich wünsche dir könnte das
gerade fühlen aber wenn jetzt nach macht
dann dann wisst ihr wie was ich meine so
den teile ich jetzt ich glaube ich mache
daraus so 14 kleine Bands drauf nehme
ich mir einfach die Teigkarte eigentlich
mache ich immer gerne nach Gefühl aber
ihr könnt auch einen Küchenwagen nehmen
und dann sicherstellen dass jeder Bann
wirklich gleich ähm gleich schwer ist
genau damit es auch gleichmäßig
durchgebacken wird aber wir müssen noch
ein bisschen Geduld haben denn nachdem
ich hier diese Band zur Kugeln gerollt
habe lasse ich sie dann noch mal auf dem
Backblech für 45 Minuten zugedeckt gehen
ich weiß es ist man nervig dass man dann
diese Wartezeit hat aber in der
Zwischenzeit könnt ihr alles mögliche
machen und nur so werden sie halt
unnormal fluffig und ich finde das ist
super super wichtig bei dem Rezept
[Musik]
ihr könnt euch übrigens so ein bisschen
an die Angabe von 45 Gramm je Teigling
halten ich habe hier die Waage habe
immer ca 45 Gramm abgewogen und dann am
besten mit viel Abstand aufs Blech legen
ihr braucht auch auf jeden Fall zwei
Bleche und ich kann mir das jetzt so auf
dass ich hier was habe ich hier drei
sechs sieben sieben Stück habe ich jetzt
hier auf meinem Blech gibt da jetzt
einmal das Tuch oben drüber einfach
damit sie nicht austrocknen so und nach
45 Minuten sehen wir uns dann bzw wir
nutzen jetzt eigentlich mal die
Zwischenzeit und machen jetzt schon mal
die Füllung die könnt ihr nämlich gut
vorbereiten und dann im Kühlschrank
aufbewahren die Füllung geht ganz ganz
schnell und einfach und besteht auch aus
nur vier Zutaten wir brauchen kalte
Schlagsahne am besten ganz kalt und
direkt aus dem Kühlschrank und die
Schüssel sollte jetzt auch nicht gerade
warm abgespült worden sein also Schüssel
und Schneebesen unbedingt auch entweder
ganz normal im Zimmertemperatur
oder dass ihr die vielleicht fünf
Minuten vorher in den Kühlschrank
stellen das wäre eigentlich auch ganz
cool weil dann können wir sicher gehen
dass die Sahne schön steif geschlagen
wird da gebe ich Vanilleextrakt dazu
einfach für den guten Geschmack und dann
lasse ich das erstmal langsam verrühren
und dann mit immer höher und schneller
werdender Geschwindigkeit die Sahne
komplett steif schlagen und der
Hauptgeschmack ist jetzt hier die
pistaziencreme und davon gebe ich jetzt
auch noch zwei großzügige Esslöffel mit
dazu das Gute ist hier ihr braucht euch
keine Sorgen machen dass das irgendwie
die Sahne flüssig macht ich meine es ist
schon eine sehr cremige und sehr
cremiger Aufstrich so soll das ja auch
sein aber es macht jetzt nichts mit der
Sahne dass die irgendwie flüssig wird
oder euch wegläuft und während das ganze
Prozedere passiert dann auch noch
Sahnefest einrieseln lassen das macht
ihr aber am besten erst dann wenn ihr
merkt dass ich so ein bisschen die
Schneebesen Muster in der Sonne
abzeichnen weil dann merkt ihr es wird
langsam fester und da kann dann auch das
Sahnefest zum Einsatz kommen
[Musik]
so die Sahne mit der pistaziencreme habe
ich jetzt einfach in einen Spritzbeutel
gefüllt mit Lochtülle das ganze so lange
im Kühlschrank geparkt und wir machen
jetzt weiter mit unseren softbanks und
schaut mal diesen richtig aufgegangen
also die Wartezeiten sind hier echt
wichtig und die werden jetzt hier noch
mal mit Pinsel wir haben ja noch ein
Eigelb übrig die habe ich einfach noch
mal einen Schuss Milch mit dazu gegeben
das ganze jetzt mit der Gabel schön
verquellen und dann einmal mit Pinseln
den Ofen müsst ihr unbedingt vorheizen
auf 170 Grad Ober und Unterhitze also
schön auf Temperatur bringen und jetzt
einmal ordentlich Pinsel und dann
ausbacken und anschließend müssen
so und die Backzeit werde ich euch
einblenden und anschließend nach dem
Backen vollständig auskühlen lassen
[Musik]
so die Soft buns sind fertig gebacken
ich finde die sehen richtig hübsch aus
und ich habe es jetzt auch vollständig
abkühlen lassen und jetzt müssen wir
eigentlich nur noch folgendes machen ein
Messer nehmen und dann einmal
anschneiden bloß nicht durchschneiden
also die müssen auf jeden Fall noch ganz
bleiben und dann mit der
pistaziencreme befüllen diese fliegen
heute die machen mich wahnsinnig die
gehören die schon zum Inventar und hier
kommt jetzt die pistaziencreme rein ihr
könnt das natürlich komplett variieren
also wenn ihr Haselnusscreme oder sowas
da habe ich mir das auch richtig lecker
vor ich wollte heute unbedingt die
Pistazien Variante machen
und da auch nicht geizen ne also das
muss schon richtig ordentlich aussehen
und was dann auch immer viele machen ich
meine so ist es auch schon okay aber wir
nehmen uns jetzt hier noch eine
Winkelpalette ich so eine so eine
Winkelpalette und dann einfach noch mal
richtig schön glatt verstreichen dann
sieht es optisch einfach noch perfekt
aus und ähm anschließend gebe ich da
jetzt noch gehackte Pistazienkerne so
als Deko oben drauf dann weiß man auch
um welche Sorte sich handelt und dann
Leute dann wird sich einfach nur noch
gegönnt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bitteschön danke danke
Zimmertemperatur aber über Nacht muss
man in den Kühlschrank
das ist richtig süß
maritazi maritazi Marie Tozzi Marie also
ich kenne diese Burger
ja wow da muss ich lecker
[Musik]
sorry
Milchprodukt so lecker wobei doch doch
da ist aber natürlich vorne mehr auf
jeden Fall das merkt man aber ist egal
Hauptsache Optik stimmt leider
[Musik]
zu essen
lange gehen lassen Muffinteig also
richtig richtig
eine Minute 37 Sekunden später
2000 Jahre später so danke
für die kurze Aufnahme
aber Leute nachmachen mega lecker
wirklich
eine sehr alternative Frau und ich
wünsche mir deswegen auch einen schönen
like das ist richtig
mega lecker macht nachmachen liken
kommentiert auch gerne bedanke für das
tolle Rezept also ich bedanke mich bei
dir sehr lecker
Tschüss bis nächstes Mal
[Musik]